[Music]
you know let's drum in our show of
course it's uh you know we've made a
little bit of news this week I don't
know if you've heard about this about
tell you why it's because on our last
New York Show which is tomorrow night
we're gonna perform a wedding right here
on this stage now I'm not talking about
a comedy bit I'm talking about a real
legally binding same-sex marriage
between our show's costume designer
Scott cronic and his partner David Gore
shine now
here's how it happened same-sex marriage
isn't allowed in California so Scott and
David we're going to get married during
our week here in New York and I thought
instead of them getting married at City
Hall when I get married right here on
the stage of the beacon and do it right
there for baby first
I believe same-sex wedding ever
performed on late-night television and
we're all very excited about it best of
all I am going to officiate the wedding
myself now I'm pretty good that's me
isn't that for everything now yeah well
anyway we announced this news stations
around the country have picked up on
this story and each one is putting its
own unique spin on it
talk-show host Conan O'Brien may be
about to push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be able to
push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be about to
push the envelope
oddly television Conan O'Brien may be
about to push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be about to
push the envelope on his late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be about to
push the envelope and late night
television Conan O'Brien may be about
the twisty envelope
late night television Oh Conan O'Brien
may be about to push the envelope on
late-night TV Conan O'Brien may be about
to push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be about to
push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be about to
push the envelope once again late night
TV Conan O'Brien may be about to push
the envelope on late-night television
Conan O'Brien is looking to push the
envelope on late-night television
Conan O'Brien may be about to push the
envelope on late-night TV may be about
you push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be about to
push the envelope on late-night
television coming to Wray may be about
to push the envelope on late-night
television Conan O'Brien may be
preparing to push the late-night
god bless
we've got us god bless our media we got
to get an envelope
[Laughter]